[Music]
Black Panther Michael B Jordan Lupita
Nyong'o and latisha right they were all
also front row at the Calvin Klein show
but the celebration started even earlier
than that at their Big Apple's premiere
I'm going to surprise the people they
show up at that theater set to break box
office records this weekend Black
Panthers premiere was the hottest ticket
in town it's also where Michael B Jordan
clued us in on those push up videos his
castmates has been posting so if you
could bet on anything and if you lose
they can give them out they can give out
push-ups whenever they want
she is ruthless okay I'm not gonna go
into this specific bit but the newest
members of the Marvel Universe also gave
us some inside info on that epic
yearbook photo they totally geeked out
over a teacher night definitely going
around nerding about and asking for
people to sign our yearbooks we caught
up with Tesla last night at the premiere
of her new movie annihilation Natalie
Portman leads the mostly female cast of
this sci-fi thriller and the ladies made
it a galentine's Day celebration many of
the ladies in my life
luckily are here I think we're gonna get
to celebrate our premiere and we're
gonna we're gonna just you know we're
gonna watch the movie for our first time
all together
[Music]